استهداف الاراضي البولنديه بصاروخ يوم
الثلاثاء اثار استنفارا دوليا واسعا لكن
بعد عده اتصالات ولقاءات على هامشي قمه
العشرين ودون توجيه اي اتهامات لاي طرف
قرر رؤساء دول وحكومات بلدان مجموعه السبع
وحلف شمال الاطلسي البقاء على اتصال وثيقا
لتحديد الخطوات التاليه بناء على التحقيق
روسيا تستعد لعمليات عسكريه
ان يحافظ الجميع على هدوئهم لهذا نحن هنا
اجراء محادثات وفهمه من الصواب ان نستمر
وانت ضربات المعلومات بخصوص مصدر الصواريخ
فان نظريه الروسيه تؤكدها تصريحات لوزير
الدفاع البلجيكي الذي قال ان النظام
اعتراض الصواريخ الاوكراني وراء سقوط
الصاروخ في بولندا فيما ابلغ الرئيس
الامريكي ومجموعه السبع وشركاه في حلف
شمال الاطلسي ان الصاروخ اطلقه الدفاع
الجوي الاوكراني الاعتراض صاروخ روسي